you're welcome all right ah welcome are
still thanks again Florian for giving
this nice talk and so it's something
really I can kind of build up on and
extend us and in short I will try to
convince you that are out your outlook
on uncertainty in machine learning
should be like this it should be bright
we should be aware of it but it should
be bright or less this boils down to not
only using point estimators but really
has whole probability distributions and
an often coined phrase is that machine
learning applications are more moving
from a lab to the machine room so what I
would consider a lab situation is that
you just have a hammer which is
supervised learning and most problems
really look like a nail and once you've
solved a problem if good prediction
accuracy you think you're done but
actually I mean what often happens for
problems kind of call for and
recommended action for example placing
orders whatsoever and I will start off
if basically just two examples that
illustrate that the first one being a
sensor fusion example so imagining
complicated machine the thousands of
sensors and you just want to know when
do I have to send a mechanic because the
machine will fail or it's gonna fail
with a certain probability so well in
the past before machine learning problem
wasn't really feasible because it was
hard to get a prediction on the failure
but I mean this machine it seems like
okay you only need a good prediction for
a failure but I mean what are you gonna
do if you predict a machines gonna fail
in one location
and another one is gonna fail in another
location so you have to kind of fight
the mechanics traveling route at the end
of the day which kind of would make up
on the out of a data science part line
you have your supervised learning for
sensor fusion plus some optimization
step for root I mean it's quite a
complicated problem but this would be
the ultimate goal basically and I mean
it's this is an example I choose because
skier that probability matters so I mean
if one machine is going to feel at a
probability of 0.9 you want to send a
mechanic first as opposed to a location
where a machine is going to fail at a
probability of 0.6 for example so let me
move over to a problem we're quite
familiar out yonder which is grocery
replenishment so this is one of her
products and real a problem is very oh
what a place orders for a grocery store
so again I will go back into the past
where even conventional algorithms our
days so the essential thing was
basically the demand prediction
algorithms were limited and only worked
fine in special situations but what
would you do if yeah right before
Christmas or inside a promotion
so this is where machine learning comes
in and very can improve your demand
predictions very much so and what most
people think and what I thought a couple
of years ago when a 20 under well that's
we transfer part everything else is
trivial you just need good demand
predictions it turned out I was wrong
and during about past years we've seen
also the parts that come after of the
demand prediction to become more
sophisticated so what you need is
actually an optimization step that
really tells the store manager or
whoever does euros what quantities were
how many pieces to order and those also
means ok probability matters because I
mean yeah might be a rare event and you
run a higher risk of selling much so
this is four point I'm going to make
two steps it's basically first one going
beyond a point estimator the second one
using an optimization behind your
machine learning pad line so what about
first seventh here I can't just build on
the previous talk so differentiating
different kinds of uncertainties first
of all the epistemic or model
uncertainty which is something you could
minimize in principle if you have more
data if you actually was in a more
suited model whatsoever so I will assume
that we have this under control and that
is more or less than reachable for a
rest of this talk so I don't have to
care about the uncertainty split
basically and on the other hand we have
the things we just can't learn with a
given data so basically pure noise which
is uncorrelated to the input variables
so I mean there's two ways of dealing
with it I mean one way is seeing okay
you realize you just want to go ahead
with your data set you see it's highly
noisy then you realize you will be stuck
in improving the prediction accuracy you
can't do anything about it so it's yeah
you realize you see it as completely
lawless this is what you end up using a
point estimator basically however there
might be some unlawfulness said and I
mean often the uncertainties that hiss
or noise statistics there is a certain
input feature and is this is often
highly correlated and so this is
something you can learn in principle so
it was basically down to predict the
probability distribution and here have
just blown an example this is what your
attempt basically you want to predict
these error bands for example so again
as Florian today I will come back to a
linear model because it's easy cuz I can
just show the whole data set in one plot
so we have a simple signal and we have
some
Gaussian noise on top and I mean we have
to address that noise with increases of
the V input variable so I will also be
assuming where they have basically
limited amount of time so that you're
just trying to set up the data science
pipeline quickly to get a first shot as
you might be are trying to use a
scikit-learn stack and yeah you want to
go for quantile regression so in you
pretend you're completely agnostic about
and also you really want to learn the
noise statistics so in here cancel
scikit-learn example which is contrast I
mean what you usually do is kind of
predict to the mean of the noise
distribution you're gonna end up with in
this example yeah the mean is minimized
by Allie square function so you just put
the least square for a loss function so
again this is just for demonstration
purposes it's a little bit of an
overkill here I can do any hyper
parameter tuning it's really chess
demonstration here so of when a
predictor quant house well for Visser
regressor and that's time I knowledge
the only one in scikit-learn currently I
just can replace the loss function and I
can give a quantile
so Florian explained how this loss
function looks like and how it comes
about and I just can have an estimator
for my quantiles for any quantile are
like so I come back to the fact that
this is not fully supporting
scikit-learn later so but I'm first
gonna show you over salts okay this is
first shot I mean simple problem but
doesn't look so bad so I'm completely
agnostic of a nice distribution function
so I learned that okay I can improve a
little bit it should be symmetric it is
not really but still but what I did here
is only pretty keen to quantize that's
enough to fly an error band
right but I mean if I really wanna learn
the whole probability distribution I'll
end up predict
further up to 100 quantiles so and again
was I mean if you do do this on a large
scale this can also result in high CPU
consumption so you might want to find
ways around depending on the size of
your problem
or if you're in the cloud and if you
have cloud costs and there's also
another downside to it what I mentioned
it's not real support in scikit-learn so
this is basically the only estimator
supporting it there's some extensions
like sake the garden supporting quantile
regression out of a box ever might be
soon an extension package offering some
sterile algorithms but still you might
end up implementing stuff yours by
yourself which if you have more time
slows you down a little bit so the next
thing is a parametric approach where you
can try so often I mean you have some
domain knowledge about your problem
which tells us something about the noise
statistics and well then you have just a
distribution function which will set a
couple of parameters usually which you
can predict so here it's just a Gaussian
distribution so I can predict a minute
variance the mean as it used to be the
variance well I can useful basically the
same regressor so I didn't do any
optimization a hyper parameter
optimization and you just can train it
with a different target namely the
square of a deviation of the labels and
the in-sample prediction for me and
what's where you end up with a
prediction for variance and you can
reconstruct the entire distribution from
it what these error pants now it's
symmetric here I should do some hyper
parameter tuning maybe or look what is
going on there that's just for
demonstration purposes and yeah I mean
it saves some CPU time if you're on a
large scale
you only need
- Fitz - predicts use usually buff it is
killing you if performance is killing
you but I mean we're so trade off I mean
you have made assumptions about the
north statistics and they can be wrong
simply so you put in some domain
knowledge but that domain knowledge
often doesn't apply to some corner cases
the worst kind of a trade off
so as for a solution I'm gonna present
so the grocery store replenishment
problem we actually went for a
parametric approach for fries CPU time
reasons plus I mean for these demand
prediction problems if quantities are
sold in pieces you can model this by
gamma Poisson negative binomial
distributions in here end up with two
parameters as Li so these are two cases
that are pretty much realistic given the
data that you usually get in such a case
also if I'll say mean the different
variance so we run certain risks of
selling quite a lot if you see her in
the second case or selling almost
nothing so that can really happen in
certain cases but you can deal with it
if you use the right optimization R
which now brings me to the second part
of the data science partner or apart I
wanna advertise a little I would say
that people might built more often so
the algorithm is something I will
explain a little bit in a reinforcement
learning language so this is not
strictly reinforcement learning I'm not
about to optimize optimize a chain of
actions but or even X action so the next
we're gonna make for a certain product
so basically what he do is we have now
this probability distributions at hand
for each day and this allows us to
propagate our state to the state in this
example is just the amount of goods you
have in store so those in the entry
level basically and just allows you to
calculate the overall costs were minus
one times four
as a function of the potential actions
like this and yeah then it's just quite
a simple minimization problem so what I
like about this method is that it's
completely retraceable so I can show you
some kind of little movie how the states
evolve so this is the example of the
first probability distribution I've
shown you so you end up you start sorry
in a state where you have just a sharp
distribution you know how much you have
in store right as of now if you go one
day into future loss broadens if you go
one more day into the future so more
Goods come in and it broadens further
and a third day it has even brought in
further so if you look here and if you
say okay what would have happened if I
had used the point estimator so if I had
predicted for example the demand is 42
gonna be 42 that's an exact number well
I would have ended up with just a single
bin here with a probability of one which
kind of seems a crude approximation if I
look at this plot here so what do we do
with it well now we can really optimize
for costs or optimize for return so
there's gonna be kind of negative
immediate rewards for two sides to a
problem one side is very just run out of
goods and you ever saw it is where they
have just too many goods in the store
and that he sings have to be thrown away
for example the bananas are brown so
Angeles is like this branch of cost
function and too low availability is the
other branch of the cost function and
you can have us just a convex problem
and you have a unique minimum and for
this your action but it can recommend
so let me fiddle around a little bit
with a dispersion or with a probability
distribution for the demand and as you
that it's a little higher so this is a
scenario that you've seen of just before
and this is a senora which is more
uncertain for example to uncertain
beverage conditions and what you observe
is that v if I actually want to minimize
at the end of the day looks quite
different so the costs here are higher
in those more uncertain scenario I mean
which reflects where you have higher
risk in general and you want to do the
least evil so to say and most
importantly also your action is quite
different depending on the uncertainty
that you have so this brings me to the
question well could I go back to the
scenario and pretty over a half point
estimator and pretend I have Seiran
certainty and if you do it like that you
might end up with a cost function that
looks like this so it's completely flat
here and it doesn't matter really what
action you take as long as it is not too
extreme like these high quantities so
basically when you would end up excuse
me there's a business rule more or less
or a human decision just trying to make
sense office optimization so you kind of
completely you lose the value your
machine learning algorithm has generated
accident I mean for me this is a clear
point that your philosophy on it is that
I mean definitely for many applications
but really make her way from a laptop
machine room
we need an optimization we need to go
beyond point estimators and I mean as
data scientists we also need to
communicate that the optimal action at
the end of the day essentially depends
on your uncertainty we can predict so
our does this it basically
of just would like to say 300 has a
booth here so we also have other
products for example price optimization
and we're also hiring the second ever we
have 20 timer for questions and so I
didn't quite understand when you've got
the propagation of your probabilities
ahead days into time are you doing like
a resampling algorithm there or how are
you actually propagating that into the
future it's more or less I mean you can
just write it down in exact equations
and put those equations into Python code
in principle so it's just convolution
integral basically so please another
question so okay if there is no and it
has a question or less saying the
speaker again
[Music]